nici gubbins has long campaigned for
recognition that a drug called Prima
dose caused her malformations and it was
her fellow campaigner Mary Lyon who
broke the news to her that an
independent review had found that she
and others had suffered avoidable harm
from primitive this the first
recognition since she was born more than
50 years ago that her lifetime of
difficulties may have been caused by a
pill her mother used as a pregnancy test
and that that pill should have been
removed from the market
we met Nikki's father when we began
investigating perimeters in 2000 you
kind of feel like you you know this is
what what was the holiest yeah Michael
Garvin's died five years after this
interview and one tragedy of his story
is so many haven't lived to see this
recognition it was only after a Sky News
investigation found new evidence
including documents showing that a
British regulator had destroyed evidence
of a link between the drug and
malformations that campaigning MPs
pressured government to launch the
review it now recommends that the
manufacturer and the state set up a fund
to support victims if this government
and the health care system ignores our
review and another medication a medical
device damages people to the extent that
we have witnessed they will and should
not be forgiven
the government has apologised for
regulatory failings but the manufacturer
Bayer says there isn't enough evidence
to show that the drug criminals caused
malformations
the manufacturer says that they don't
have a moral responsibility what do you
say to them
there has been avoidable harm in the
case of prema dass we talk about
psychological avoidable harm and
and on that basis alone there is this
moral and ethical responsibility to
contribute to make amends the end is in
sight but recommendations are only that
until political will makes them a
reality only then can these reluctant
campaigners put away their banners Jason
Farrell Sky News